hey did just you know they're shooting
me right now for the hispanic heritage
thing
so don't say some don't say something
crazy
because you're on speaker right now it's
gonna be on video just giving you a
heads up
i think we've come a long way as far as
latino representation but we still got a
long way to go it obviously doesn't
represent
the demographics and the way they
changed we
went to these auditions there was a lot
of little white kids and one
there comes my little latin boy it was
hard
then he didn't get the fart started
complaining i'm going damn
what's the truth miko what's the matter
with you being that we're the fastest
growing demographic you would like to
see the same represented
on screen because if you don't
it is very discouraging as a young
person and you start to sort of question
yourself worth if
you're not seen
anyone sitting here teresa i guess you
are ac
excuse me i just said it's a beautiful
day
oh no espanol what
boy you really don't speak spanish do
you
oh no no i took french in high school
you know the
language of love
slater's an anglo-me you're latino
well i guess somebody in my family needs
to change it come on
slayer chicano studies why do you care
about that
because i'm chicano until two days ago
i didn't even know my real name was
sanchez my dad changed it 25 years ago
to get into the military academy
can you believe it he felt he had to
hide his heritage to be accepted
i don't want to do that
[Music]
i mean one thing that i'm proud of as a
culture and with our people is that
my dad's always trying to instill it
into me and my mom for that matter is
you know we put our head down we go to
work don't complain
don't find excuses don't try to have any
sort of victim mentality
i'm a child of immigrants and i
appreciated
everything my parents did to come to
this country and provide for us
how did it come about that the whole
acting thing well you were a dance
competition
and they needed a boy to play paul
rodriguez's nephew yeah you got to tell
them the whole thing no more that was
lord
let me tell you what you were talking
about yeah how did i get in wait a
minute
well that's how it started no i didn't
that wasn't the first thing no no no
do you remember the first audition when
you took me to l.a yeah i took you to
many auditions
yeah did you remember the first one
first one let me tell them do you
remember the first one do you remember
the first one dad hell yeah
i mean yes i do aka apollo was the very
first one well yeah
that was it and you auditioned for
normal lear
after eight eight callbacks whatever it
was but you didn't trip out having to
bring me to l.a because sometimes it'd
just be like i remember the auditions
were like five minutes sometimes then we
turned around i was a two and a half
exactly
and you you you went out for a lot of
stuff that you didn't get
it was tough it was tough getting there
remember we had to change your clothing
and stuff like at a taco bell
you know when the restrooms in the gas
stations yeah like that i remember that
and it was
it was hard all of it was hard we didn't
have any
like entertainment backgrounds mom and i
they asked me what do you think how much
you pay and here i'm going
how would i know that you know in my
mind i remember the
finishers concrete make 300
a day right i said well i double in a
triple and then i said
so much they gave you double that's what
i said
you know to me a guy making you know six
hundred dollars a day is a lot you know
working hard
paying them twelve hundred dollars a day
for nothing he wasn't working
you know they just wanted to hold him i
don't know about nothing
you know not yet you didn't do nothing
for a while remember
yeah i remember i remember yeah what's
the matter buddy tell you the truth dude
so i was in shock never really sunk on
me a lot till you were like 15
16 years old then i'm going damn i think
it's
gonna be somebody
ac i'm really glad you're here
[Applause]
man i've definitely got to learn spanish
you